today we are having the group of
Colombian football students they are
giving the work to riverside park
they've been coding trees within bagging
leaves cleaning trash all kinds of work
that takes place in parts we've been
working very hard for three weeks
already and they would chip in today
we've been working in this garden for
two weeks because it was really bad you
know it's very hard but you know the the
kids need this park and in order for us
to keep this part 1 we have to have
groups from everywhere helping us
Colombia has been very helpful and this
check these children they need to enter
in interact with the community and this
is the best way that they can interact
with the community working around the
people and doing stuff that they they're
going to experience what this community
is all about